if a guy's trying to sleep with you he'd
be like ah nah he ain't [ __ ] and girls
find 80 of men unattractive eighty
percent
interesting that's fine 55 roughly
percent of women attractive you don't
why would why is that interesting to you
you don't think that girl's like
guys that
other girls like you know girls like
guys or other girls like yeah they
guy though girls like guys not other
girls like yeah because because you want
because it's a competition
um I don't know because I didn't I don't
think I'd go for the girls that the guys
that other girls like there's a certain
thing that I like about a man so so the
thing that you sort of got like a
certain way some girls you don't think
most girls will if they know they can
keep him
like like if a girl could that's let's
if this is an extreme example but Drake
how many girls are lined up to date
Drake nobody's thinking oh he has too
many girls around him
yeah I guess yeah and but if girl and
most girls if they thought they could
keep him and retain him they would hook
up with Drake yeah for sure yeah but the
thing is like a lot of girls know you'll
be one of many
yeah
they're okay with that women women that
have a man of that state of Drake status
or whatever status it is they don't mind
being one of many
because they because they know the deal
because they know that other girls like
him yeah but that yeah that's part of
his crop that's being an artist that
that's the kind of hat you have to put
on your audience or your fans will like
you but your one person is so if we if
we now bring it to the quantum quote
real world it happens here too so when
women in the average woman is looking at
men she's looking for that top 20 guy
when we ask women what type of man do
you like what does he need to have what
does he need to have what does he have
to look like women tend to choose men in
a top 20 percent
so if if 80 of women or majority of
women are choosing that top 20 of men
hmm
how many options can change isn't it
because what makes them the top 20 is a
collection of things right and those
things can change those things are
attractive to women oh okay so so
they're attractive to women so those is
that why the relationship's broken down
then because they're going for the 20
and then stuff too because I I don't
know because I'm just saying if those
top 20 of men have 80 of women to choose
from so you girls are all good numbers
you girls are all going for 20 of men so
if if if 100 of women are going for 20
of men who has the options here so you
women yeah no I get it exactly what
you're saying but so you could easily
pick so the thing about women is you you
go you women are not honest you don't
pick the men that women other women
don't find attractive and you don't pick
the men that other women don't want so
there's loads of men when you think
about how many guys are out there you
could easily pick one of these guys and
they would worship your feet they would
just be so happy yes that's what I want
no but you don't you don't but you don't
know
you don't no you don't you don't because
if you did right now you've been married
listen you'll be married just called off
an engagement right oh
Revelations yes okay that's what I'm
saying don't get confused like my the
the nice guy the sweet guy the guy that
looks after his mom the guy that doesn't
have a lot of money
actually I have a question was it always
that way so you said you're the nice guy
the sweet guy has it always been that
way no the guy that I told you that he
kissed another girl he was like the cool
guy like super super tall like yeah got
all the swag when would you say that
switched where you were looking for when
did you start looking for the nice guy
uh well uh sorry that's difficult that
guy that I just explained he came about
because he saved me from a very bad guy
who was a fugly ugly oh a fugly so my
type has like always been like I I don't
know I'm attracted to like
uh the the not the not um uh typically
or stereotypically beautiful men he was
cute the one you just showed me so when
when you say you called off an
engagement
yeah so he was going to engage he was
going to propose one day like people let
it slip and then I kept on hinting like
I don't think it's the right time it's
not the right time it's not the right
time yeah okay and then he didn't like
the Rings there the Ring's still sitting
in hand Gardens like after a while like
I just realized that it wasn't gonna
work so why because there's just too
much going on right yeah two too much
going on
was it was he a good guy
I wasn't a good guy
so then why would you accept the ring
then it doesn't make anything I didn't
accept I know but I'm saying I called it
off I know at the point of us going to
like look at rings I thought it would
work and then the realization kicked in
so I didn't allow myself
what you sound like to me is you sound
like you've dated Bad Boys you've been
attracted to Bad Boys not not the ones
that would take you down the aisle and
at some point you realize actually I
need to change what I'm doing yeah
that's what I just certain okay so so
but initially you're given so this is
what women do right you spend the you
spend your 20s to the point when you're
in the 30s chasing the wrong types of
men then once you get to your 30s you
realize actually I shouldn't be doing
this right and you've you've been
chasing off Chad and Tyrone and then
your options start to diminish and at 30
you're like okay what the hell have I
done but in reality there will be men
you're pretty woman there'd be men that
would have taken you up that would have
happily done this but you'd aired them
you literally did not see them and the
reason why you didn't like this loyal to
crap yeah no but so but the thing is the
history generalizer isn't it it's what
women no but it's like you're telling me
something I already know so I'm trying
I'm letting you land no but she's
agreeing so basically the reason why I'm
saying this is because I've we've done
we've done this show we speak to women
like if you use your 20s and you end up
in your 30s and you do not have a man
you've had from at least 17 18 you had
about 12 years for you to lock it down
if you didn't it's not because you
didn't mean any good men it's because
you literally outweighed your options
and now you end up at 30 years old and
now you're competing for women in their
20s with the men that you would want so
then so then and this is what happens
with men in their 30s and 40s right
that is when they become more
established and that is when they become
a little bit more attractive
um you know most millionaires don't
become millionaires until they're like
30 late 30s early 40s sometimes 45 and
so the men that are that have watched
the women right they've watched women
curb them I don't want them eyes are
geek guys at this these are that I don't
like him they've watched that throughout
their 20s and then they've established
themselves and they're watching now the
same women who didn't give them any time
now like oh my God I I want those type
of guys in their lives
not me love yeah that's what they think
they're like not me because when it was
time when I was kind of showing you
exactly who I was and being a good guy
and I could be a good guy you wanted the
fogs on the street that would get your
door kicked in at four o'clock in the
morning yeah I've never I've never
wanted that personally that's never been
my entail thing and I don't think that I
think there are a lot of women that do
go through that process and they waste
time you go what's cool what everybody
says is the in thing or the good looking
guy or whatever but I think it's about
choices that I think you decide what
kind of life you wanna have some people
go for the whole looks and they have to
be attracted to their partner some
people I think it's down to your love
language and what you're laughing about
a person you don't think that younger
women in general tend to date more bad
boys than older women
in general
we have to be honestly be honest there's
a stereotype for a reason the crazy high
school boyfriend yeah I know it's a
thing but I don't think it's across the
board I think there's a certain type of
person that goes no and I understand
that but the thing is like the average
age of first marriage in the UK is 31.
and this is just general feedback we're
getting from men where they're saying
we're tired of these girls have been run
through by the bad boys in their 20s and
the 30s they take me yeah right and it's
I'm not saying every single woman not
every girl does that or they become Born
Again virgins and they go to church
you know they fight they find God and
they say oh my God I'm I've got two baby
babies for these crazy baby fathers now
and I'm just gonna be a Christian so I
really hate that song like seriously
this whole born again virgin thing even
the thing even when you're saying you
can get surgery you cannot erase the
amount of things that were put inside of
you it's like for for us men it's quite
it's not the amount of things
does anyone here Believe In Born Again
virgin no girls believe in it because
they keep saying
I'm a born-again virgin thank you very
much I'm telling you everything from
months I don't think anyone actually
believes it they might believe a guy
away which that's kind of I just think
like we always said like what use is it
yeah of running up like and what tends
to happen is you girls end up running up
your body count between your teens your
20s and your late 30s in your 30s then
you actually decide that I should want
to get with a man what got you what good
uses 10 20 30 bodies that gonna come to
your husband they don't actually there's
no use at all in actual fact you come
here with more damage and more and um
more distrustful man that's why when you
meet new women so they tend to be like
I've got trust issues but none of these
trust issues came for me I just met you
but that's what we're talking about as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tic Tac and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible